hello John Perry here you are about to
watch a talk that I did at the College
of Charleston I did the talk on Darwin
day of 2018 and you don't actually have
to watch it you could probably just
listen to this while you're cooking or
whatever but there are two spots in it
where I show stated clearly animations
you might want to watch during those
parts because there's a lot of fairly
important visuals going on there but
especially if you're already familiar
with my work you've already watched most
of my animations you've probably already
seen those it's the miller-urey
experiment animation and the RNA world
hypothesis animation so you know feel
free to just keep listening while you're
cooking or jogging or whatever it is you
happen to be doing without further ado
here's me talking at Darwin Day 2018
just out of curiosity has anyone ever
seen a stated clearly animation like Oh
quite a few you I made those so I I
really want this to be kind of a loose
discussion and this is kind of get
people used to learning things out and a
little bit more comfortable with each
other in the classroom here I want
people to kind of break into groups of I
don't know four to six people and see if
you can figure out amongst you just
using your brains no whoo no googling it
flight evolved four times the true
flapping flight and four different
lineages of animals on planet Earth can
you figure out which four of those are
so let's just kind of like breaking the
grip real quick talk about that
introduce yourself to someone you don't
know and think if you can figure it out
okay so I think that's enough time can
everybody hear me now with this
microphone even in the back okay all
right what did you come up with just
start start saying them what are the
four different lineages that flight
evolved within pterodactyls pterosaurs
in general birds insects and mammals
mammals being of course bats right so
good work I'm gonna be talking today
more about chemical evolution than
biological evolution how did life emerge
as mentioned I do animations on genetics
and evolution I've got a bunch of them
on the website at stated clearly com if
you want to go check those out I also
have my youtube channel you can follow
me at on twitter at stated clearly and
it's Darwin week so we're talking about
evolution and Darwin's Darwin's big
discovery was natural selection people
had suspected that evolution or common
ancestry was a thing for a long time
since ancient times actually but it
wasn't seriously considered because
nobody knew exactly how it would have
happened how did life diversify and do
so in the incredibly successful ways
that we see living things the way that
they're built today how on earth could
could the order in complexity they that
exists in life how could that come about
and Darwin discovered that the the key
missing component to this was natural
selection so he described evolution as a
very simple sort of equation descent
with modification which just means that
when parents have offspring those
parents are slightly different than each
other and slightly different than their
parents they descend with modifications
and then that is acted upon by selection
natural selection being the the main one
that he talked about but there's also
sexual selection and you know now that
we have humans meddling with things
there's artificial selection when we
selectively breed animals and plants and
so on and if you have descent with
modification plus selection you get
adaptive evolution that was his big
contribution to science was figuring
this out and
has enabled us to understand all kinds
of different things the theory of
evolution is extremely applicable not
only has it helped biologists understand
how new species evolve which is really
interesting but it's also helped farmers
better manage pests we learned how pests
adapt to our attempts to kill them and
we found ways using evolution
understanding evolution how to outsmart
their their adaptations governments have
used our understanding of evolution to
manage animal populations we see this a
lot with fisheries I'm from Oregon and
we have we care a lot about salmon there
and we we use a lot of evolutionary
theory to manage salmon populations the
wild in that we also have domesticated
salmon now that are raised in hatcheries
and nations are using them to manage
epidemics so we use our understanding of
evolution to control things like cholera
and other outbreaks of diseases we've
actually been able to tame cholera in
certain circumstances by understanding
how its evolves and how it reacts to
different pressures that we can put on
either with medications or with cleaning
the water we can actually get cholera to
evolve into in certain forms that we
want that we want it could be more
benign and then finally and this is kind
of more recent we've been really
applying evolution that that equation
that Darwin came up with descent with
modification plus selection equals
adaptive evolution we've been applying
that to our understanding of cancer we
now see cancer as you have a cell line
that rebels essentially in your body it
starts trying to reproduce and evolve on
its own it really becomes its own little
organism inside of you that your immune
system that has to fight and if your
immune system fails to fight it if it if
it's able to adapt and evolve fast
enough it can escape that attack from
the immune system and you actually have
a battle between the cancer and your
yourse other cells and seeing cancer in
this light has allowed us to to make
several breakthroughs and cancer
treatment not only that but we are
actually evolving drugs now in the lab
there is a drug called imatinib which is
for the treatment of chronic myelogenous
leukemia
and to create that we use Darwin's
equation we we had a molecule that
worked somewhat well and we used a
process that mutated that molecule and
then we tested it against different cell
lines different cancers until finally we
got one that worked really really well
and had very few side effects and so
we're we're using this as an engineering
tool now to engineer molecules and
they're actually engineers that do like
buildings and windmills and things like
that that are actually using a similar
process they're using dart that process
that Darwin discovered so it really has
changed the world it's changed how we
think about biology it's changed how we
do things as a civilization and not only
that it's also answered a couple of my
favorite little questions you know
curing cancer is cool but it also helped
us figure out which came first the
chicken or the egg if you look back in
the fossil record you find that amniotic
eggs they emerged at least 312 million
years ago we see the first amniotes
can anyone describe what an amniotic egg
is a profit pond that's good yeah
and the amniotic egg the the amnio the
amniotic membrane is a special membrane
that evolved allowing animals to lay
their eggs on land instead of depending
on the water and keep that moisture in
it won't dry out the first amniotes we
suspect evolved about 312 million years
ago there's several different species
that emerge around that time and it
appears that they are no longer stuck at
the water's edge they could actually
travel out and lay their eggs on land so
that 312 million years ago and then the
first chicken if you want to count
Archaeopteryx
would have been somewhere around a
hundred and fifty million years ago so
the egg came first we finally know we
can finally answer this child's riddle
also how much wood would a woodchuck
chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood a
woodchuck would chuck as much wood as a
woodchuck should in order to survive and
reproduce within its prospective
environment
[Laughter]
so yeah cancer curing cancer is one
thing but now we can answer this but
there are a few questions that a simple
appeal to evolution cannot answer one of
which I don't know if Darwin was really
bothered by it but people certainly have
been perplexed by this since then Darwin
did think about it a little bit but this
is a line from the end of his book the
his original his first edition of the
book a very famous line he says there is
grandeur in this view of life with its
several powers having been originally
breathed into a few forms or into one
and that whilst this planet has gone
cycling on according to the fixed law of
gravity from so simple a beginning
endless forms most beautiful and most
wonderful have been and are being
evolved and the big point I want to talk
about here is that he here just didn't
even try and answer the question about
the origin of life he said that these
these several powers having been
breathed into a few forms or into one
that's what got it all started and this
is the language he's using is kind of
it's it's very biblical and it there's
the breath of life in Genesis and it was
an appeal to the popular ideas at the
time - relating to what people called
the vital force people who were studying
biology and even chemists who were
studying biology believed that there was
some sort of a vital for something that
science didn't understand maybe
something that science could not ever
understand maybe there's something that
could never be studied or understood
there was something spooky about living
things there was a ghost in the machine
people believe that all organic
chemistry the things separated organic
chemistry from you know general
chemistry was this vital force it was
producing these organic molecules
Darwin's language here made a lot of
sense to people at the time just to note
those several powers that he's talking
about here that is the ability to
reproduce in order for evolution to work
again we need descent with modification
acted upon by selection and descent with
modification requires some sort of
reproduction or replication that is
imperfect there has to be variation
offspring cannot be eyed perfectly
identical to their parents if they are
you won't get any evolution things will
just stand still and so those several
powers that he's talking about here that
that is the ability to reproduce the
vital force was actually kind of falling
out of favor among scientists a little
bit before Darwin's time this is
Frederick volar he was a German chemist
and one day while doing an experiment
messing around with some molecules he
accidentally made urea he made pee
without peeing and this doesn't really
seem like that big of a deal but a lot
of historians kind of put this as the
big thing that that made at least
chemists give up on the idea of the
vital force because what he did is he
made an organic molecule using only
general you know basic chemical
reactions and when we realized this was
possible I mean urea is a pretty simple
molecule but when we realize that this
was possible everybody started tinkering
and experimenting and trying to figure
out what else we could make what other
biomolecules could we make using just
normal chemical reactions and that that
really opened up the door eventually for
experiments and thinking about the
origin of life what volar began to
uncover is that life is not powered by a
vital force at least it doesn't seem to
be
it's powered by chemistry living things
are chemical systems we are extremely
complicated chemical systems but we are
chemical systems and when we start to
think of ourselves that way it's not
always fun to think yeah I'm a chemical
system but when we do that that opens up
the door to all sorts of medications and
all sorts of innovations that are really
applicable to our lives today one of the
other things that it opened us up to was
speculation that life emerged from
chemistry and in 1952 that speculation
became legitimate scientific experiment
and I've got an animation I want to show
you that talks about that first
experiment the miller-urey experiment
stated clearly presents what was the
miller-urey experiment it was once
believed that if you left food out to
rot living creatures like maggots and
even rats would simply poof into
existence the idea was called
spontaneous generation a series of
experiments starting in the 1600s
disproved this idea and in the 1800's a
new scientific law was proposed life
only comes from life it's true that rats
maggots and even microbes are far too
complex to simply poof into existence
but in 1859 English naturalist Charles
Darwin
put forth the theory of evolution in it
he showed that under the right
circumstances relatively simple
creatures can gradually give rise to
more complex creatures given this
information serious thinkers began to
wonder is it possible that simple
life-forms actually could come from
nonliving matter
not by poofing into existence but
through a natural gradual process
similar to what we see in biological
evolution Darwin himself mentioned this
idea when writing to a friend but if and
oh what a big if he wrote we could
conceive in some warm little pond with
all sorts of ammonia and phosphoric
salts light heat electricity and so on
present that a protein compound was
chemically formed ready to undergo still
more complex changes in 1924 Russian
biochemist Alexander Oparin published a
book which he titled the origin of life
in it he outlined his thoughts on a
gradual progression from simple
chemistry to living cells he imagined
the early ocean as a primordial soup a
rich collection of complex molecules
produced by natural chemical reactions
in this soup further reactions could
take place eventually producing living
cells at the time Darwin's warm little
pond and opens primordial soup were
really just speculation they were
founded on a good understanding of
chemistry and biology but they could not
be considered legitimate scientific
hypotheses because no one had found a
way to test or observe them science
after all is the study of observable
facts and an ongoing conversation about
how those facts can be best linked
together chemical reactions like those
proposed by Darwin and O Perrin are not
expected to leave an observable fossil
record without either having fossils to
examine or a time machine to travel back
and observe what happened
how could scientists even begin to study
the origin of life in the 1950s Stanley
Miller then a graduate student at the
University of Chicago came up with an
idea we could simulate early Earth
conditions in the lab and then carefully
watch what happens if you can't study
fish in the sea set up an aquarium
working with his professor Harold Urey
Miller designed an apparatus to simulate
the ancient water cycle together they
put in water to model the ancient ocean
it was gently boiled to mimic
evaporation along with water vapor for
gases of the atmosphere they chose
methane hydrogen and ammonia
these are simple gases which scientists
at the time thought were probably
abundant on the ancient earth they added
a condenser to cool the atmosphere
allowing water molecules to form drops
and fall back into their ocean like rain
the ancient earth would have had many
sources of energy sunlight geothermal
heat and even thunderstorms so they
added sparks to the atmosphere to
simulate lightning the goal of the
experiment was not to create life but to
simply test the first step in O Perrins
model can simple chemistry naturally
give rise to the complex molecules of
life after running the experiment for
just one week their ocean became
brownish-black careful analysis revealed
that through a series of reactions many
complex molecules had been produced
among these were amino acids special
molecules of life that we once thought
could only be built inside the bodies of
living creatures
this was a pivotal breakthrough in
science so significant in fact that it
gave rise to an entirely new field of
research now known as prebiotic
chemistry scientists don't know for sure
if the gas is used by Miller really were
the most common gases of the ancient
earth because of this many experiments
have since been done showing that the
molecules of life can form in a wide
variety of environments with different
starting chemicals and different sources
of energy sugars lipids and amino acids
have even been found on meteorites this
suggests that the molecules of life
formed all throughout the ancient solar
system and may be forming right now in
other regions of our galaxy
together these discoveries tell us that
Oh Perrins primordial soup and Darwin's
warm little pond could have easily
existed in one way or another on our
ancient planet so to sum things up what
was the miller-urey experiment the
miller-urey experiment was our first
attempt at simulating ancient earth
conditions in this case the ancient
Earth's water cycle for the purpose of
testing ideas about the origin of life
the miller-urey experiment is
significant for two main reasons
first though it was not a perfect
simulation of the early Earth it clearly
demonstrated for the first time that bio
molecules can form under ancient
earth-like conditions second the
experiment took what was once mere
speculation the idea that life may have
emerged from chemistry and transformed a
portion of that speculation into
legitimate testable science many
questions remain to be answered about
the origin of life but scientists from
many nations in many fields of study are
now following Stanley Millers lead
they're finding ways to turn those
questions about the origin of life into
testable scientific hypotheses
simulation experiments cannot tell us
exactly how life formed in the past but
if enough of them are done they could
eventually tell us if it's possible for
life to emerge from chemistry
I'm John Perry and that's the
miller-urey experiment stated clearly
alright how's my animation on the
miller-urey experiment any questions on
that my animations are done I draw them
in flash I've got a Wacom monitor so I
can draw right onto my monitor and I use
flash it's actually it's now Adobe
animate they just changed it the
branding on it but I do everything in
flash then I transfer it over to Adobe
Premiere and put it out as a video
upload it to YouTube usually takes about
two months to do an animation any
question questions about animation stuff
or how how the heck I got this job all
those things are welcome yes what's that
the first one that I did was in 2012 the
first stated clearly animation I had
been tinkering tinkering with it before
that my background is actually in art I
studied graphic design just at a
community college my education felt like
it was not very good so I but I found a
website called lynda.com that teaches
you how to do all sorts of used all
kinds of different software and I
learned animation on that website and it
was never applicable to my job I was I
was building websites and designing
logos for people and I hated my job and
then in the side I would do science
lessons and upload them to YouTube the
first one was what is DNA and how does
it work and that's one of the ones that
has over a million views people started
to started using it like crazy in their
classrooms and then I talked to add
questions about the origin of life so I
talked to Nicolas HUD who is the
director of the Center for chemical
evolution I figured he'd know if anyone
I just called him during office hours
which is a fun trick if you ever if you
ever find yourself outside of a academic
community and you want access to
professors the top people just call them
during office hours and they they will
answer their phone and so I talked to
him he got excited about what I was
doing and ended up giving me a grant and
that was the first paid project I did
doing this sort of thing and now it's
all I do so
I work for different universities
different research groups and I work for
in the private industry I work for
cancer research groups it's been quite a
ride I've been doing this now yeah since
2012 and full time for about three years
now
as my actual job so I'm not sure that
can with the conversion question I'm not
sure you might know that yeah well yeah
as far as the purity goes I'm actually
not sure the period that they started
with but there's lots of easy ways to
tell if you your molecules are
contamination or if they if they
actually came from the experiment and
we're actually just talk about this
yesterday one of the ways is you know
living things have certain carbon
isotopes that we can test for so you can
test for contamination that way and
there's also the chirality of the amino
acids if you have a mixture of
left-handed and right-handed molecules
then you know that they were actually
produced in your experiment if you have
only one or the other there's a
possibility of contamination there so
the stuff that they make you're looking
for a molecule that's pretty small
you'll probably find it and it becomes
an analytical challenge of actually
determining what all molecules are
present and they actually have to do
these like fractionation is based on
solubilities and like they add acid to
dissolve some things that bases dissolve
other things it's pretty complicated to
like separate all the molecules out
because it's
complex myths there's actually a lot of
amino acids in that mixture that are not
found in biology right so there's
there's plenty of mino acids in your
proteins and a lot of a lot of the ones
that you make in those mixtures are not
in your body and then some of the ones
that are in your body are also not in
those mixtures so that's kind of a
separate question of how did that go
that first amino acids that kind of
chemically evolved to what we have today
and whether that happened kind of after
biology started or early on the earth
but the answer if the reaction is pure
or not it's not pure it's very it's very
impure and it doesn't really matter like
you can you can add in different gases
and things and make different compounds
but a lot of you still you'll still
generally make amino acids I'm just a
tip don't do this at home once you know
what you're doing you're basically
making a bomb so you're pressurizing
these gases in like a little container
so this can't be done very safely but
make sure you talk to a chemist before
yeah so one of the only thing that the
miller-urey experiment showed us was
that yes it is possible to get these
monomers but how on earth you get once
you have these monomers how do you sort
them into you know a high enough
concentration for some sort of you know
useful chemical system to emerge we're
nowhere near replication right
replication is the big goal in life
origins chemistry is to get to a a
system naturally under under
circumstances that would have existed on
the early earth before anything alive
existed we want to be able to go from
that to a chemical system that can
replicate itself make a copy of itself
and that we are we have not answered
that question we're a long ways from
that but we're take we're tackling this
question from both ends so we have we
have experiments that are starting with
sort of these dirty chemical mixes like
you get in the miller-urey experiment so
we have people that are starting there
and trying to move towards something
that might look
like a self-replicating system and we
have researchers that are starting with
that are starting with living cells and
trying to figure out how simple can you
get this system to be and have it still
work so people are going out of both
ends and what we found when we study
life there's been a lot of excitement
around RNAi so we have DNA and we have
RNA there's a lot of excitement around
RNA as being possibly the first chains
of RNA being possibly the first
self-replicating entities because chains
of RNA first of all they're found in
every single living thing including
viruses which some people may or may not
consider to be alive and an RNA is it's
it's crucial to wait to replication I
mean chains of RNA are what are being
replicated genes are what are being
replicated if we really look at biology
we can actually describe biology
completely from the level of a gene it's
it's kind of like describing the video I
just showed you with zeros and ones it's
not always useful to look at life at the
level of a gene but genes are the
simplest replicators and RNA is the most
likely candidate that we know of right
now for being the original replicator
and so with that I want to show a video
about the RNA world hypothesis this idea
that life that RNA was the first
replicator and
yeah
yes not in the miller-urey experiment
but in other experiments we have and we
really don't have we we don't have any
experiments that I know of maybe you
know some that I don't that are
producing those in a high enough yield
for the RNA world to work yet wrong
krishnamurthi just published a paper
probably two months ago with a possible
solution to that but ribose which is the
sugar that RNA is made of you get you
got a sugar and a base the bases are
produced readily and miller-urey type
experiments but the sugars are not they
don't last very long ROM krishnamurthi
thinks that he might he he's he's
discovered something that might might
lead to stable sugars either stable
sugars or really rapid production of
them so that even though they are not
very stable they're being made so
quickly that they end up being stable in
a particular system but that is still
one of the questions that's that's
unsolved is how do we get high
quantities of RNA nucleotides and DNA
nucleotides for life to originate one of
the other options for that we found
several other alternatives to RNA that
might have been the first the original
replicating molecules and that's being
investigated by Nicolas HUD in his
laboratory he's got several different
different things that he's looking at
but that is one of the big problems in
life origins chemistry but this one that
we're gonna see is kind of working from
the cell backwards to RNA and pretty
much everything in the middle is still
pretty mysterious we can go back to RNA
and then we hit a wall
stated clearly presents what is the RNA
world hypothesis if you were to go back
in time 120 million years you'd find
yourself in a dinosaur world 500 million
years ago was a world of trilobite sand
other strange sea creatures 3.4 billion
years ago was the world of the first
living cells and if you were to go back
further still scientists suspect that
chains of a chemical called RNA or
something similar to RNA kick-started
this entire beautiful mess that we call
life RNA is thought to have given rise
to life for several reasons chains of
RNA are found abundantly in all living
cells today RNA is a closed chemical
cousin to DNA and with very little help
from researchers RNA chains can
replicate evolve and interact with their
environments while many details have yet
to be worked out the RNA world
hypothesis is the simple idea that
somewhere on our early planet perhaps in
a tide pool or hot spring the Earth's
chemistry was producing random chains of
RNA once formed they began replicating
evolving and competing with each other
for survival as these chains evolved and
diversified some eventually began
cooperating to produce the genetic code
a wide array of complex proteins and
even living cells which from the
perspective of RNA can actually be
thought of as houses or survival
machines for RNA to live inside to
understand how RNA chains can interact
with our environments replicate and
evolve we first need to understand the
simple process of base pairing chains of
RNA are made of nucleotides small
molecules that come in four different
types labeled a C u + G the backbone
atoms of a nucleotide shown here as a
yellow bar can form strong chemical
bonds with the backbone atoms of any
other RNA nucleotide this means that
different chains can have completely
different sequences from left to right
the parts we call the basis of
nucleotides the colored sections labeled
AC EU or G are attracted to other bases
sort of like a magnet but they're
selective about who they will stick to G
selectively pairs with C a selectively
pairs with you when bases find their
matches and stick together we call it
base pairing researchers have found that
with a little bit of assistance base
pairing allows chains of RNA to
replicate and evolve here's how it works
when a long chain of RNA is suspended in
cool water with high concentrations of
free nucleotides the chain can act as a
template for its own replication
nucleotides automatically base pair with
our partners on the existing chain if
their backbone atoms form chemical bonds
with each other and by the way this is
the part that currently requires
assistance from researchers we're not
yet sure how this would have happened in
the wild a complementary RNA strand is
born one with the exact inverse sequence
of the original if the water is then
heated paired bases lose their grip
allowing both chains to act as templates
when the cycle repeats the great thing
about this process is that every other
RNA chain produced as a copy of the
original
but sometimes mutations slip in this
means that his chains compete for
survival and reproduction true evolution
descent with modification acted upon by
selection can operate on chains of RNA
as amazing as replication is base
pairing also gives RNA chains a second
special ability when placed in water
cool enough for base pairing but without
enough free nucleotides for replication
chains will fold up and base pair with
themselves the end result is a complex
shape with certain sticky bases pointing
outward because they weren't able to
find partners these sticky
outward-facing bases can cause unique
chemical reactions by interacting with
other molecules in their environment a
folded chain of RNA capable of guiding a
specific chemical reaction is what we
call a ribozyme
some ribosomes break certain molecules
apart others join certain molecules
together a ribozyme a specific function
is determined by its specific shape and
its shape is determined by its sequence
if a mutation changes a ribozyme
sequence the shape can be modified and
so can its function
when ribosomes were first discovered
scientists wondered how difficult it
would be for random chains of RNA to
evolve legitimate survival functions
imagine for example a ribozyme that
could build nucleotides out of molecules
it finds in its environment across
multiple generations natural selection
could promote and refine this ribozyme
because the chain would tend to have
access to more free nucleotides than its
rivals allowing it to replicate more
often to explore this idea
researchers at simon fraser university
produced a large group of random RNA
chains and examined them to see if any
happen to be able to make nucleotides
surprisingly some actually could but
they weren't very efficient researchers
selected out the successful chains and
then used a lab technique called PCR to
quickly replicate them with slight
random mutations after just ten rounds
of PCR followed by selection highly
efficient nucleotide building ribozymes
evolved these are molecules with a
lifelike ability to actively participate
in their own survival these ribosomes
and many others produce through similar
experiments are beginning to blur the
line between living things and simple
chemistry so to sum things up the RNA
world hypothesis is a simple idea that
the first things to replicate and evolve
on our planet may have been chains of
RNA or something similar to them while
the basic idea of the RNA world does
seem to give us a promising pathway to
the origin of life it's still very much
a work in progress as mentioned one of
several unsolved problems is how did
nature get backbone binding to function
without the special enzymes or lab
techniques we use today while many
researchers continue to focus on RNAi
others are investigating alternative
molecules chemical systems that might
replicate and evolve without assistance
and could have given rise to our
a continual breakthroughs are being
found in both avenues of research I am
John Perry and that's the RNA world
hypothesis stated clearly so there we
have it the the RNA world hypothesis I
just want to open up to questions now
well I guess before that just just to
mention that between the production of
amino acids we're actually getting small
pep small proteins now as well with the
work that Jay is doing there's there's a
pretty big gap between things like the
miller-urey experiment and things like
the RNA world hypothesis obviously we
saw that that people have to intervene
to get these systems to work the really
neat thing about RNA is that you can you
start out with random chains and they
evolve an incredible array of different
abilities and we think that different
RNA is cooperating and exploiting things
like amino acids and small proteins in
their environment could have actually
given rise to the genetic code and
everything else because these RNA chains
they act a lot like organisms do and
that some of them will end up
cooperating with each other there's a
really neat experiment where they had a
bunch of RNAs that were replicating with
enzymes so when I stalk about enzymes I
mean modern biological molecules are
helping them replicate and they also put
in there an RNA s-- enzyme so an enzyme
that wants to digest RNA so basically we
put in a bunch of random chains of RNA
we put in molecules that allow them to
reproduce and we put in a predator
to attack them and they started to
cooperate with each other to avoid the
predator they evolved all sorts of weird
techniques to do this and it's really
fascinating it's like we're looking at
little animals little single single
chains of RNA that act like animals it's
a very fascinating field of research
super promising we just need to find a
way now to connect that back to things
like the miller-urey experiment so with
that questions
on my animations I actually figured I
just think I want to do animation on
this and I called the researchers and
asked them if they want to help me with
it and if they want to fund it and if
the answer is no then I'll move on to
something else but the Center for
chemical evolution has me do one a year
and I love this topic so I get really
excited I'm hoping I'm trying to
convince them to let me do my next one
on the origin of the genetic code how do
you go from RNA replicating to RNA
building proteins and keep my fingers
crossed hopefully they'll let me do that
because that's a really fascinating
topic but yes
if I find that there's a conflict like
that I tried to make sure that I put
that in the video so like with this
video I tried to make sure that it was
very clear that there major aspects of
the RNA world that we have not solved
that's how I deal with that I mean most
most research groups know that I mean
you know if there's opposition to your
findings and I'll usually try to show
the papers that are in opposition to the
findings as well or have links to them
in the video description that's how I've
been dealing with that because I have
had that happen several times actually
where someone's really excited about
this one thing but there is opposition
and so I show that I make sure to make
that clear in the video they'll just
give a talk where there's no data it's
just all these ideas and then there's
always thankfully it's always one person
that's like where's where's the data
right and it's definitely just I mean
most of the things that John showed
today or not not like is well I'm even
though RNA world has some opposition to
it I guess but it's important to always
keep in mind in the science aspect of it
right if you're gonna if you're gonna
pose a question or like pose a claim you
need to have some type of scientific
evidence to support it and it's
certainly in certain kind of subsections
of this field there are kind of camps
where like some people like an example
is kind of like the Darwin's warm little
pond thing like all the chemistry's is
in like enclosed body of water versus
hydrothermal vents under the ocean right
so some people think a lot of orders of
life in chemistry have
I took the role Vince but it's not it's
not really a like it has to be one of
the other like obviously we don't know
what it was and so I think most good
scientists in the field would are
willing to kind of have space for
multiple viewpoints on some of these
things obviously there's always a couple
cooks and then you feel we're like this
no this is how it happened we weren't
there so we don't know exactly how it
happened it's more about thinking about
what was most plausible and what we can
scientifically test well so if you're
asking like the most complex molecule in
a military-type thing I do you mean
complex as in biological and complex or
because I'm sure I'm sure there's huge
just random things that pop out of it if
you consider that complex but as far as
like the largest protein so you know
it's only like a former I believe yeah
what's with what's the longest protein
you've done and to answer your first
question about what's like the biggest
thing these molecules called Dolan's
these like really hydrophobic kind like
clusters of carbon cycles and that's to
define them on meteorites - but we don't
really think they do anything like
biologically relevant because they're
super insoluble so like imitating like
analyzing
basically eat them up with acid but yeah
I mean there's there is tons of stuff in
there and and we're really just
scratching the surface of what we know
like what what we're finding and
unfortunately um where there's probably
a lot more in there that we are actually
we're kind of eating away the molecules
when we do when we dissolve it or when
we do the analysis right things like
sugars are really fragile molecules and
so even if sugars were present that the
chemical sample preparation we do to
analyze the samples is probably
degrading them even before we can see
them yeah as far as complex RNA is the
one that I showed in the video is
probably one of the most complex that
that we've been able to like not only
produce through evolution experiments
but then actually analyze to try and
figure out how it works because you get
a bunch of weird stuff a bunch of weird
polymers and it's takes a lot of time
and money to actually figure out you
know what their sequences and you know
what what it is that they're doing but
we get all there's just all kinds of
complicated things that happen the thing
that I find most interesting and I wish
I'd have to pull up the the website to
remember what the name of the paper was
there's a review on RNA experiments and
that in there they talked about this the
predator avoidance system it's actually
not just one RNA chain it's involved in
that avoidance it's - and they're
cooperating with each other to make sure
that they can both replicate frequently
enough to survive and make sure that the
only nucleotides that they ever have
exposed our ones that the predator can't
attach on to it's a really neat kind of
symbiosis between these two RNA strands
I would say that's probably the one of
the most interesting ones that's
happened that we've been able to figure
out how it works
that was really it was it was the
question that I couldn't find good
materials on if I'm gonna spend a bunch
of energy producing an animation
producing in one of these videos I want
to do it on something there's not
already a whole bunch of really good
materials out there already and the
origin of life I could not find anything
that was good I was reading all kinds of
books and it was all really complicated
and I wanted to make something simple
that you could understand and you know
middle school high school level and so
that's why I decided to do origin of
life I guess it's just grown it's hard
to tell if demographics have changed
that much because it's hard to track
demographics until you have a large
enough audience and the other thing
that's tricky for me is teachers show my
videos in classrooms YouTube only gives
me data on you know how old is the
person are they male or female but
that's whoever owns the YouTube account
that's being played on so there's
actually a bias in YouTube stats for
kids stuff to adult men because kids are
using their dads account a lot so it's
actually sort of hard to track just with
YouTube statistics but I got bigger yeah
okay there's a couple of things that I
think gives me an edge over researchers
and the first thing is that I'm learning
all this for the first time right before
I create an animation and the benefit
that I have with that is that I'm having
all these aha moments and I remember
them I remember all the things that
finally clicked so as you're studying
whenever you have one of those crazy aha
moments where it just feels good like I
finally understand this take note of
that and remember it and bring that up
every time you're talking to someone new
in the field or someone who just has
questions about it because whatever
clicked for you is probably gonna click
for somebody else as well and there's
this you know the curse of knowledge by
the time you've got your PhD you forgot
what it's like not to know what you know
and it becomes hard to communicate to
your next-door neighbor about what you
do the other big thing is to avoid
jargon jargon is actually super
important jargon is just new vocabulary
words that scientists invent so they can
shortcut and have conversations with
each other that makes sense but you have
to learn all those words and they're
complicated words and sometimes people
just add extra words for no reason I
have a talk that I do called superfluous
jargon is an impediment to communication
some people don't get to that title as a
joke there's so many words we were used
to flowery words in science people add
extra words when they're doing
scientific journals and when they're
writing to make themselves sound smart
and that's exactly the opposite thing
you should we should be encouraging just
use normal language and if you're gonna
use jargon explain what it means first
and then you can use it in the rest of
your you know spiel but those are the
two the two big things keep your
language simple and remember your aha
moments
you
you